the the problem with reparations is what
what percentage of white people do you
think actually owned slaves i don't know
it's less than one percent really yeah
and the other problem is money doesn't
solve poverty if money solved poverty
then like people could just throw money
at a poor person and they'd become rich
but lottery winners they're like they go
broke faster than anyone how to spend it
yeah it's about like managing money and
being able to run a business like i
think reparations possibly at the top
like at the time
but you can't like like how you're
making people that didn't do anything
pay for something their great great
great grandparents did even if you did
the direct descendants
like most people immigrated here after
slavery like my like i have a
grandparent from lithuania or a great
grandparent from life oh you're saying
that okay okay like and you have to
understand even and then what about the
white people that fought on the other
side that fought against yeah
so it's it's almost like like i just
don't know how that would work